[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
agression russe en ukraine le sénat se
mobilisent
le 23 mars 2022 alors que le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky s'apprêtait
à intervenir en direct vidéo devant le
parlement plusieurs sénateurs emmenés
par nadia sollogoub présidente du groupe
d'amitié france ukraine se sont rendues
devant l'ambassade de la fédération de
russie pour y remettre une lettre
appelant au respect du droit
international
les quelques 170 signataires issus des
différents bords politiques de la haute
assemblée dénonce une situation
contraire aux règles du droit
international en particulier à marioupol
elysium
il appelle avec la plus grande fermeté
le gouvernement de russie à ouvrir
respecter exempté d'opérations
militaires et sécurisée des couloirs
humanitaires pour les populations qui
souhaitent fuir vers l'union européenne
il appelle également avec la plus grande
insistance le gouvernement russe à
permettre l'acheminement du
ravitaillement vers les populations
civiles et l'intervention sécuriser des
ong et à mettre en oeuvre un cessez le
feu sans condition
il demande à la fédération de russie de
ne pas se soustraire ce que commande le
respect de la vie humaine et à
l'ambassadeur de relayer cette exigence
à son gouvernement
peu de temps après ce geste fort et
trans partisan les élus ont rejoint
l'hémicycle pour écouter l'intervention
du président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky
devant la représentation nationale le
président a comparé la situation en
ukraine aux ruines de verdun et a
demandé aux entreprises françaises de
quitter le marché russe
ce même jour le groupe
interparlementaire d'amitié france
russie a regretté que l'ambassade de
russie à paris se livre à une campagne
de désinformation scandaleuse absurde
pour les parlementaires la communication
des autorités russes s'apparente ainsi à
une tentative orwellienne de
construction d'une réalité alternative
pour légitimer une agression et des
modes d'action inacceptable
gérard longuet président du groupe
interparlementaire d'amitié france
russie souligne par ailleurs que les
allégations bus portant sur l'emploi
d'armes banni par le droit international
font craindre le risque d'une escalade
intolérable dans ce conflit
pour en savoir plus consulter les
communiqués de presse
[Musique]